belle arti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
nuovo io sono parigi oggi parliamo di
relazioni una volta un mio amico mi
disse le relazioni sono come i dark
souls delle interazioni sociali ecco
questa è la cosa più bella che mi sia
stata detta negli ultimi anni per chi
non sapesse dark souls è un videogioco
che è impossibile da finire c'è un
casino che più o meno come esempio si
presta quella che è la realtà perché le
relazioni parlando in questo caso di
monogamia
mettono a confronto due persone che sono
diverse ovviamente per natura che si
legano questa cosa genera sempre
disguidi per quanto generi anche
positività piacere tutto quello che non
è semplice perché due persone non
possono matematicamente andare d'accordo
su tutto è impossibile proprio
matematica anche impossibile sta a voi
capire quali cose non mi vanno a genio
della persona e se quella persona vale
abbastanza la pena per poter passare
sopra queste cose e viceversa l'altra
persona con voi vi racconto un po come
me la vivo io e quali sono stati i miei
problemi a livello relazionale vediamo
se possono minacciare un po con i vostri
o cose simili comunque ci tengo che voi
mi dite la vostra nei commenti come
sempre perché poi mi leggo tutto il
lavoro molto di più leggendo e
rispondendo che facendo i video
praticamente allora io ho sempre vissuto
le relazioni in modo un po strano nel
senso che fino ai 18 anni 17 non non era
mai uscito con una ragazza in quel senso
che era un po nerd in un po represso un
po timido un pò in tutto ciò tutto io
con obi la mia prima ragazza perché fu
lei a scrivermi su facebook ai tempi io
degli sposi per
la prima ragazza quella con cui ho fatto
i primi video anche su youtube se vi
ricordate
da lì io ho iniziato a diventare
conosciuto quindi non ho mai avuto una
relazione prima di essere fa vj ecco
questo quindi io sono sempre stato un po
comodo nel senso che ho sempre aspettato
che delle persone mi scrivessero per poi
iniziare a parlarci
sbagliando perchè alla fine non è che
devo essere sempre io la la prima donna
cioè nel senso quella che deve essere
rimorchiato colui che doveva essere
rimorchiato voldemort e queste j cairoli
mi avesse introdotto nel mondo di harry
potter mi avrebbe nominato come colui
che deve essere rimorchiato una cosa del
genere perché sto sempre stato
rimorchiato io questo non vuol dire che
a discapito della canzone che ho fatto
bevi pagherai tu le ricche e ironica
ovviamente
non vuol dire che non ho mai fatto atti
di cavalleria o cose del genere quali
touch ci mancherebbe però non ho mai
parlato io per primo e non ho mai
mostrato interesse aver prima con questa
cosa qua perché essendo io timido non
riescono anche a farlo in modo semplice
mi ritengo un tenerone nel senso che non
ho mai fatto quello che su quello che
sfrutta la propria posizione di
rilievo per conoscere un miliardo di
ragazze non è mai stato così anche
perché io le relazioni le vedo che per
me sono sacrosante nel senso che per me
stare con una persona
a lungo termine
questa per me è la felicità nelle
relazioni non è averne tante con tante
ragazze e divertirsi no per me averne
una
è buona è tutto veramente tutto perché
sono un solo un ex romantico e come
titola così con quel di najla questione
romanticismo eccetera vi spiego un po
come l'ho vissuta e anche dei problemi
che ho avuto e ve li dico adesso
praticamente io non avendo mai avuto una
ragazza prima dei 17 anni dice 17 18
anni se io sono arrivato a un certo
punto in cui ero
non solo venire da questa frase in modo
non kringe quindi crimi già tappatevi le
orecchie gli eroi pieno d'amore da dare
la jacko perfetto basta ero detta questa
cosa della grigia telegiornale detta ne
avevo così tanto che quando ho amato per
la prima volta poi non ho mai smesso di
amare con quell'intensità anche nelle
mie relazioni future io ho sempre amato
tantissimo fa solo quello che fa le
vocine tenere eccetera c'è un'altra cosa
volevo dire tra l'altro che ho letto nei
post di alfa women mi pare
che dice tipo ho sentito due persone che
che parlavano con la vocina tutta tenera
quelli non trombano
comunque ritornando sul discorso io ho
vissuto quattro relazioni importanti
cioè proprio storie serie durate tutte
quanti in media un mezzo 22 al massimo
adesso non sono fidanzato ma il mio
problema grande ed è qui che volevo
arrivare e che io sono una persona
purtroppo
che non sa stare da sola ok ma non c'è
un motivo o forse sì è solo che non lo
so
io sto bene da solo ok perché il
problema più grande è tu devi stare
questa è questa una verità mondiale tu
devi stare bene da solo punto da solo la
sola dovete stare bene da soli i
conoscere una persona diventa un plus
nel senso tu stai già bene il per conto
tuo tu puoi vivere senza quella persona
puoi vivere benissimo ma conoscere
questa persona da un plus alla tua vita
ok questo così si vive punto perché
sennò vivi nei confronti di una persona
poni tutta la tua felicità nei confronti
di quella persona quindi dipendi da
quella persona è sbagliatissimo è
sbagliatissimo è come essere dipendenti
da un qualcosa che ti dà dipendenza e
poi ti tolgono quella cosa e tu sei
perso perché non sai stare con te stesso
senza quella cosa lì ecco sbagliatissimo
quindi voi dovete stare bene con voi
stessi e poi avere una relazione che vi
porti altro quindi altra positività e va
beh questa è una cosa che magari anche
banale e scontata da dire ma ripeta la
non fa mai male ecco è sempre su questo
punto vorrei dire io mi sono sempre
vissuto le mie relazioni così
intensamente che per me non averla è un
peccato
ok c'è nel senso io so come mi sento
quando sono fidanzato con una persona e
sto bene so che quella persona entra a
far parte di me proprio come ma proprio
a livello non so come dirlo quando
quella persona raggiunge un traguardo
ok c'è se io sto insieme una persona che
frequenta l'università e da un esame e
prende 30 del massimo dei voti
io c'è per me quello è anche un mio
traguardo perché sono talmente legato a
quella persona che si trovava di
diventare un po anche me sono
orgogliosissimo che è di questa cosa e
viceversa ovviamente quando vi raggiungo
i miei
quindi ogni vivo proprio c'è se la mia
vita da 1 a 100 e bella cento con una
persona può arrivare essere bella 200 ok
non è che senza quella persona diventa
50 20 fatto un esempio chiaro questo mi
porta a una negatività però che la
transizione che o tra una relazione e
l'altra è sempre negativa perché io non
so stare da solo per questo motivo
perché tra me e me sto bene ma so che mi
scatta il fatto di non avere un'altra
persona vicino perché so quanto sarei
felice e quindi cerco non disperatamente
quella persona ma non sto fermo per i
cacchi i miei cioè apro i direct lista
gran vado a vedere chi mi scriveva sono
persone potenzialmente interessanti per
me stessa cosa con facebook lo faccio
quando esco parroci insomma non me ne
sto per i cazzi miei ecco questa non so
se proprio una mega positività
perché molti mi dicono che io faccio ho
fatto questo discorso con tutti i miei
amici e molti mi dicono sì hai ragione
ed è statisticamente è vero che più tu
rimani nel gioco e più facilmente trovi
la persona giusta per te e vero però è
anche vero
che non darsi il giusto tempo potrebbe
farti prendere bene potrebbe farmi
prendere bene di una persona però poi
non è quella giusta ok perché non mi
sono dato abbastanza tempo ecco io sto
cercando di fare questo nelle mie ultime
delle azioni quando lo finite ho cercato
di fare questo c'è di trovare una
persona non
pensando a che peccato questa giornata e
da 100 e poteva essere da 200 se solo
fossi stato con una persona giusta per
me
ecco questa è una cosa un po un po
negativa ma allo stesso tempo
che non so bene ancora come superare
purtroppo però sono ognuno se la vive a
modo suo un imperfetto di essere il vate
il guru della delle relazioni perché ho
i miei difetti anche io ci mancherebbe
uno tra tutti il fatto di non riuscire a
stare da solo
però comunque si impara sempre insomma
si matura si impara e normale un'ultima
cosa che volevo dire in questo macro
argomento sempre per non tediarvi per
non parlare tutto il giorno perché anche
qui ci sarebbe da parlare in modo
incredibile l'orgoglio ok l'orgoglio
nelle relazioni è il nemico più grande
che c'è secondo me cioè a me è capitato
di stare con delle persone con le quali
non ci eravamo fatti niente c'è proprio
non ci aveva mai traditi non sono mai
mancati dispetto e poi non ci siamo più
iscritti perché c'è l'orgoglio di mezzo
a perché tu mi hai lasciato quindi non
ti scrivo più se tu mi dici a siamo
stati bene la [ __ ] cielo penso magari
magari lam pensato ma non hanno scritto
è un errore nel senso che alla fine
l'orgoglio non esiste secondo me nelle
nazioni è che dovremmo sdoganare questa
cosa secondo me non c'è nelle relazioni
un vincente e un perdente non esiste ok
innanzitutto io odio lasciare ok
preferirei venir lasciato e non sto
scherzando ve lo giuro su chi volete io
odio lasciare una persona perché poi sto
male
poi continua a pensare sempre al fatto
di l'ho lasciata io quindi potrei far
finire questo dolore a me e alla persona
che alla quale io ho voluto un sacco
bene che mi dispiace che stia male
potrei far finire il dolore di entrambi
dicendo ah no scherzavo
riproviamoci quindi hai un fardello in
più il fatto che sai che non funzionava
devi comunque provare a resistere a non
scrivere quindi ancora peggio invece se
vieni lasciato non ha il potere di
scrivere ok ora ognuno anche qua c'è il
proprio parere change my mind io la
prossima volta preferirei venir lasciato
che lasciare questo sicuro che nel mio
caso è vero perché poi io quando mollo
ci sto male come la persona che è stata
mollata quindi non è che ci sto male di
meno perché ho mollato io no ci sto male
uguale in più quel problema lì del fatto
che posso ritornare sui miei passi
facendo finta o no scherzavo ok quindi è
peggio per me mollare
il discorso è proprio il fatto
dell'orgoglio quando tu ti lasci con una
persona o anche mentre ci sta insieme
però succede qualcosa subentra
l'orgoglio a non scrivo per primo io
dire iscrivermi prima lui perché
io sono incazzato e poi rimanete tutti e
due online su whatsapp a guardare la
città online e nessuno scrive niente
questo è un problema che secondo me ci
sono passati tutti e ci passano tuttora
tutti quanti
perché esiste l'orgoglio boh io l'ho e
stirpe ray dalle da dall'essere umano
l'orgoglio non serva anni ed orgoglio
distruggere le cose veramente
siate forti passateci sopra perché
l'altra persona
quando voi fate il primo passo quando
invece siete orgogliosi in realtà
secondo me l'altra persona apprezza il
fatto che voi siate stati
coraggiosissimi a mettere da parte
l'orgoglio quindi siete più forti voi
che avete vinto l'orgoglio secondo me
nelle relazioni non ci deve essere un
vincente e un perdente non è che chi
lascia un vincente che viene lasciato un
perdente no non esiste non c'è non è una
canzone a classifica non è ma gara
solo uno stare bene vivere le giornate a
pieno quindi
mettete da parte l'orgoglio il più
possibile so che non so che è
impossibile metterlo totalmente da parte
ma il più possibile fatelo perché
deteriora per nulla perché poi nel tempo
svanisce e questa la stronza grande di
tutte che nel tempo svanisce l'orgoglio
perché quando passano anni
che poi non provate più niente per
quella persona e quella persona non
probabilmente per voi quindi siete due
sconosciuti di te ma ora che peccato che
quella volta non non abbiamo risolto in
questo modo solo per orgoglio che adesso
non c'è più perché l'orgoglio è
temporaneo e dura veramente molto poco
il fatto è questo dipende poi dal
problema che si è creato però di base
cioè c'è stato un tradimento vai un
altro discorso ovviamente però per le
cavolate l'orgoglio dura veramente poco
quindi i giganti è un problema portando
la rottura di una relazione per orgoglio
uno dei più grandi sbagli che si possono
fare secondo me è però è questo il mio
punto di vista come del resto tutto il
video amate siate rispettosi della
persona che avete di fronte
rispettate anche voi stessi insomma
questo è il più possibile un bacio ci
vediamo il prossimo video iscritti al
canale lasciato momento da sotto e come
sempre
da ragazzi
[Musica]